we're on problem 27 and they stell us if
I is equal to the square root of -1 then
what is 4 times I that's an I times 6
times I well multiplication is
associative you can switch the order
around so this is the same thing as 4
times 6 times I times I or the same
thing as 24 times I squared right and if
we square both sides of this you get I
squared is equal to negative 1 I squared
is equal to negative 1 so this is 24
times negative 1 so it's minus 24 which
is choice C next problem 28 they want to
know what an equivalent form of 3 plus I
is and a lot of times people don't like
either when you have a you know square
root in the denominator or they don't
like it when you have it a a complex
number in the denominator a complex
number is just something that has part
real and part imaginary right so the way
you can do it with this case is you
multiply times the conjugate of this
number and I know that sounds like a
fancy word but all it means is you take
the opposite of the imaginary part so
what's the conjugate so you want to
multiply this times and remember the
only way you cannot change a fraction is
if you multiply the numerator the
denominator by the same thing because
then you're multiplying by one so what's
the conjugate of this the conjugate of 3
plus I is 3 minus I 3 minus sign if you
do 3 minus I over 3 minus I right and
I'm doing that cone you multiply a
complex number by its conjugate you end
up actually with a real number and then
you're going to end up with a complex
number up here and a conjugate all it
means is you keep the real part the same
and you take you change the sign on the
imaginary part that's all that word
means all right now let's figure out
what this is equal to 2 times 3 just
same distributive property as always let
me do it in green 2 times 3 is 6 2 times
minus I is minus 2i all of that over 3
times 3 is 9
three times minus I is minus 3i I times
3 is plus 3i and then I times minus I
you could view that as minus I squared
right and let's think about what this is
equal to well this plus 3i and the minus
3i cancel out and what's I squared well
this is equal to negative 1 so you end
up with a minus of a negative 1 right -
of a negative 1 is +1 so you're left
with 6 minus 2i over 9 plus 1 over 10
and actually we can reduce this sum we
could divide the top and the bottom by 2
so that becomes 3 minus I over 5 just
divided both numerator denominator by 2
and that is choice B choice B problem 29
these go-fast 29 no systems of equations
and all that what is the product of the
complex numbers 3 + I + 3 - I they just
asked us that that was in the last
problem when we multiplied 3 plus I
times 3 minus I what did we get we got
10 we did this whole thing 3 times 3 is
9 3 we did the whole thing so they're
just repeating the same question that
equals 10 that's choice B rewind the
video and see what I did here 3 times 3
is 9 times minus 3i plus 3i minus I
squared that these terms cancel out you
get a minus I squared which is minus
negative 1 so you have 9 plus 1 so the
equals 10 so that is choice B that's
crazy they just gave us the same problem
twice in a row let's see
all right they're giving us more and
more imaginary problems but these are
fun especially if they're going to
repeat the same question problem 30 if I
is equal to square root of negative 1
I'll just keep writing it because they
keep writing and it's good as a reminder
I is equal to the square root of
negative 1 and a and B are nonzero real
numbers what is 1 over a plus bi well
once again if they kind of want us to
rewrite this they probably just want us
to get rid of the eyes in the
denominator so we multiply times the
conjugate of this complex number so we
multiply times a plus bi the conjugate
over the conjugate right a plus bi the
conjugate isn't this whole thing the
conjugate is just a plus bi oh sorry we
should be multiplying times a minus bi a
minus bi over a minus bi and the
conjugate of a plus bi just to get the
terminology right is just the a minus bi
but I'm doing a minus bi over a minus bi
so I'm not changing this fraction
because this obviously is 1 you know x
over X is the same thing as 1 so let's
see what this is equal to well the
numerator just becomes a minus bi times
1 which is a minus bi and you have a
times a which is a squared a times minus
bi so it's minus a B I then you have B I
times a which is plus a bi I'll write it
down here plus a bi and they cancel out
and then you have B I times minus bi so
that's minus B squared I squared right
so let's see these cancel out and so
you're left with a minus bi over a
squared minus B squared I squared but we
know what I squared is I squared is
equal to negative 1 all right you square
both sides of that you get I squared is
equal to negative 1 so this is the same
so if we multiply this becomes a
negative 1 but then this negative and a
negative they cancel out you get a plus
so then we get a minus bi over a squared
plus B squared and that is choice that
is Troy
be choice B next problem okay alright
what are the solutions to the equation x
squared plus 2x plus 2 all right now if
you if you see an equation like this and
you're like okay let's see you can i
factor it oh and that is equal to 0 you
say okay what number is when I multiply
them equal 2 and when I add them equal 2
well that's a hard one and it whenever
you get stuck the easiest thing to do is
just use the quadratic equation right
and just as a reminder if you have the
if you have the problem if the equation
is ax squared plus BX plus C I maybe I
should have done them all in capital
letters is equal to 0 the solution of
this and the proof of this we've done in
the Khan Academy it comes from
completing the square but it's useful to
memorize is negative B so the solutions
are X are equal to negative B plus or
minus the square root of b squared minus
4ac all of that over 2a so in this case
what is a a is the coefficient on x
squared so a is equal to 1 what is B B
is the coefficient on X so B is equal to
2 and what is C C is just a constant
term so C is equal to 2 and we could
just solve like that just substitute
these values so you get X so you get X
is equal to minus B which is minus 2
plus or minus the square root of B
squared so that's 4 minus 4 minus a so 4
minus 4 times a 4 times 1 times 2 times
2 all of that that's an ugly-looking
radical all of that over 2a 2 times 1 is
2 so that equals let's see we get minus
2 plus or minus the square root of 4
minus this is 8 right 4 times 1 times 2
4 minus 4 8 which is minus 4
- for all of that over 2 which is equal
to minus 2 plus or minus so the square
root of -4 we could rewrite that as the
square root of 4 times minus 1 right so
that equals 2 plus or minus the square
root of 4 times the square root of minus
1 all of that over 2 which is equal to
minus 2 plus or minus square root of 4
is 2 and the plus or minus carry you
know so it's dealing with positive or
negative 2 times the square root of
negative 1 what we learned that's I
multiple times the square root of
negative 1 is I all of that over 2 and
we could simplify this a little bit I'll
do it in a different color just because
I've run out of space at the bottom here
so this is equal to divide everything by
2 the this you get negative 1 plus or
minus I and let's see the choices are
right that's choice C because negative 1
plus or minus I could also be written as
negative 1 plus I as 1 value for X and
then the other one could would be
negative 1 minus I and they separate it
out they don't write plus 4 minus in the
actual problem and I'm out of time I'll
see you in the next video